the loft just cracked the pepper in my
head
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by jacob lordy he's
an actor you know from his role as nate
jacobs in the emmy award-winning mega
hit hbo series euphoria his latest
project though is the film deep water an
adrian line directed psychological
thriller set to hit hulu on march 18th
jacob belordy welcome to the show thanks
for having me man so you know we've had
a lot of sauces from australia in the
lineup before many of them mega hots how
deeply growing up did you explore what
seems to be a robust hot sauce
subculture down under you know what i
had
absolutely nothing to do with the hot
sauce subculture strangely enough
i have an uncle who's like
a fairly large man
um and he's sort of rough his guts he's
from the mines and he
loves he's not rough as guts he's a good
bloke but um he loves hot sauce so
whenever we're in like a small town
somewhere there'd be like a little old
lady that made some extreme hot sauce
we'd always have to get it for him and
bring it back so that would be the
closest i came to it
[Music]
oh it's on the wing it's already there
you even have to apply it
[Music]
heat with hot yeah you can really tell
so your latest project deep water marks
the return of adrian line the creative
force behind films like indecent
proposal flash dance jacob's ladder just
to name a few
what is it about deep water that makes
you nostalgic for films of the past you
had an interesting quote where you said
that you hoped that it's the rebirth of
these kinds of films again yeah i feel
like there was an era um
especially in the 80s
when we
sort of had come out of the 60s and 70s
of cinema with this sort of easy rider
you know those kind of films and then we
went sort of back into this
studio genre
which was like
you know psychological psychosexual
thriller through the 80s and 90s and i
feel like
it felt like growing up to me like there
was one of those coming out every week
and even though they weren't like
the greatest films
they had something like iconic about
them like almost something noiri about
them sort of like that era of cinema and
i feel like we've gone so far down
another end now with everything being
fantastic and large and green screened i
was like excited to get back into like
just sort of
something psychological that's still
entertaining you know
okay
[Music]
i'm feeling a little bold
oh confident yeah after that first wing
that's not the way to go yeah okay it's
a little like
it's definitely like
yeah
[Music]
i had a few people give me
give me i was talking to halsey last
night and she was like she was like you
know take tiny tiny bites like don't put
your fingers on your face and the first
thing i've done is just go oh and then
like
go to touch my head
be careful around the eyes that's where
i'll be
uh anya you know careful around the eyes
so we had david chang on the show he had
lots of nice things to say about
australia but he did bury the burgers
calling them an abomination because
australians put beats on them and i
think that it's only fair that we offer
you our platform to respond do you have
a defense for the australian bird
absolutely i think australians make the
best burgers in the world
um
because they put everything on them like
a burger in australia isn't just um it's
happening now
the burger
the burger the stream and the burger in
australia is like
eggs and bacon and avocado and then a
patty and then like six cheeses and then
a mayonnaise and i think that's
incredible i think the more
the more the merrier on our burger
that's an absurd statement i don't like
beets though
beets sometimes pineapple with the
australian burgers
for me that's absolutely no chance am i
doing that i feel like fruit and
fruit and meat
my mom used to make this mango chicken
salad and it would piss me off so much
every time and it tasted good but it
[ __ ] made me so mad i was like like
there's this delicious chicken and
delicious mango and you [ __ ] them by
putting them together
i hated that
[Music]
i like this little branding little
marcus aurelius looking
okay
i'm still got the last one still
saying something
well why do you like this
there's a little bit of a cumulative
effect you know as you go you know the
chemistry of all of them okay
i have the chemistry of all
i like that
so as i understand it euphoria season 2
is shot entirely on kodak ektachrome
film which is almost impossible to find
and i know that you're romantic when it
comes to cinema what would you say a
show like euphoria stands to gain from
shooting on 35 millimeter
i think like because every other aspect
of it has so much thought and so much
care
to then shoot on film is like another
degree another level of effort that you
have to put in and you actually can't
get the film they made that film for the
show
so just in terms of history there's
something quite incredible about about
being a part of something because you
know you have guys like nolan and
tarantino always saving film always
talking about you know shooting their
pictures on film to save film but then
to have
film kind of come in and
help you like to to to invent something
or to reinvent something rather that's
like very special to me anyway
personally to be a part of something
like that you know and you just see it
being loaded every time you're shooting
like every single frame of this
could never have existed before we shot
this like this is
it's so yeah i don't know there's
something about that precious or sacred
yeah and like i you know
vainly i get to be on
a frame you know multiple frames of that
film that's like that's pretty that's
pretty unique experience you know and
then another thing that's unique about
the cinematography on the show is the
use of color to represent a character's
emotional state yeah you know i think a
lot of people use colors in the way that
especially how they were using the first
season
to be like oh i want to make a movie
like
drive you know or oh i want a movie that
looks like this or a movie that looks
like that whereas what you just said
rings true i think sam doesn't use the
color because someone's used it before
and it's like kind of sexy he'll use it
to tell a story through the character or
like marcel was speaking this season
about having filters
that were
over the lens that made it a memory that
made it a dream what is it like to
relive childhood and memory shots and
like everything's used practically to
evoke a feeling and i think that's the
thing i like the most about sam and then
can you draw back the curtain on that
single-shot carnival scene from euphoria
episode four the scope of it is so
ambitious yeah i mean there was stitch
points there were little stitch points
throughout the thing but we spent a
couple of nights shooting that and i
remember
they
were editing it
as we shot it they'd take the card out
and then run it to a building and they'd
edit it to make sure that the stitch
points so sam worked that out
in real time like he was like where can
we stitch it he it wasn't composed until
they composed it on the you know sort of
on the on the spot and was
such a cool shot to watch i love
watching
the phoenix
angry goat pepper
[Music]
of them have a little bit of a delayed
reaction now that we're teaching you
everything about hot sauce today but
some of them why do they do that
you take a bite
you feel good about it and then about 30
seconds later
[Music]
so i've heard you talk about studying
the groundbreaking work of actors of
yore from brando to james dean to
montgomery clift is there an actor that
you'd say influenced some of your more
unique character development tactics
like i was interested to read that you'd
keep a journal from the perspective of
your character
i think james dean said something like
how can i lose i've got marlon brando in
one hand
and montgomery clift in the other
and i think that actually kind of
applied to a lot of what i was doing
that i wanted to do with nate was
to have
the sensitivity of montgomery clift to
have these eyes like a wounded deer you
know but then to have the brute force of
brando coming in and ripping stella's
clothes off you know what i mean like
so i think
funny enough your question is the answer
like
that's probably what i i drew from all
of those kinds of people how can you
have
like a
a great softness and a sadness in your
eyes but still be like
yo what the [ __ ] good you know what i
mean like yeah this this weird contrast
is what i try to dance between i think
with it and then off the top of your
head without thinking about it too much
your favorite brando movie of all time
and why
uh on the waterfront
um just for the one-way ticket to
palooka ville when he's in the car with
his brother that line is [ __ ] crazy
you know could have been somebody that
could have been something you know
you was my brother with that kind of
thing i like that that's a different
movie that's um god godfather too but
same sentence the point stance point
stance something about it you know what
i mean that kind of thing
[Music]
guess i'm a spice guy huh you're a
spaceman
spy is that what you call yourselves yes
please it's a very exclusive club yeah
we meet
i'll take it i wasn't on it
i have many leather-bound books
oh a big one
yeah
as we get more confident
this is the time you should be getting
less confident
is that a thing the closer you are to
the peak you get more confident but it's
the most perilous part of the journey
well i like that outlook i've never
heard it delivered quite so eloquently i
like that i like that as an outlook
through the whole thing but no
to answer your question typically up
front big bites cleaning wings as we
work our way down the line you start to
see smaller and smaller lights
from this side of the table that's not
me small to big yeah there we go there
we go that's how we're doing it
all right jacob we have recreated
segment on our show called explain that
graham we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll pull the
picture up over here on the monitor you
just tell us the bigger story so know
that you're an avid photographer on set
not just when you're stealing other
people's phones for selfie prints
what began your interest in photography
and why is it important for you to bring
a camera onset
i think heath ledger definitely started
it um because i'd seen uh i'd seen a
documentary of his and it was sort of
all told through his photos and and
super 8 footage that he had
and when i left home
the journey seemed so big and so
unrealistic that i knew i would like
forget it so my mom bought me a my canon
camera to just like make sure i was
snapping every single beat um try to
keep it all i guess
yeah this is the first magazine i ever
did it's called uh v man and i was that
thing was reflective of me
so there's another picture on there and
it's the film version of what the
photographer was shooting while i was
hanging out what do you do with all your
photos do you archive them i just hold
them yeah i've got them all i've got
most of them printed and
i just go back on them and you know get
teary every now and then
this is uh quite the celebrity row here
at msg you got seymour leo on one side
and then you got leave schreiber on the
other side do you remember what you're
pointing at here
and it was probably me trying to act
like i knew like
like did you see that sport
did you see that just happened right
there that three was crazy you know like
i have no idea what's going on oh number
three blocked him good huh
got him so good
so i was trying to be one of the guys
you know because you can also there's so
many cameras watching you when you're on
the front row so it's like not
it's an enjoyable experience but the
whole time you know this little voice in
my head is like don't look
like an idiot like look like anyone
scores i'm like
you know it's like me and sparkly like
you're gonna see this now i think i'm a
phony [ __ ] man
[Music]
i've seen great men fall at this point
too so
not the champion jacob the champion
maybe tear up
hello your dad
oh you're so much fun
[Music]
so we had jeffrey dean morgan on the
show he had some interesting thoughts on
an actor's psychological approach to
playing a villain saying that a villain
doesn't know that they're a villain
how would you describe your relationship
with playing a detestable character like
nate jacobs if you'd even call him
detestable
yeah i mean you know i've been over this
so many times and i've been dragged
across the coals for it and i and i've
had a conversation with my mom i was
like i will not stop defending him like
because like that's my that's my baby
you know i've like i've made
him and and there's no way
i don't think anyone could give a
performance
if i was sitting there being like man
this guy is
like a detestable piece of [ __ ] because
then i wouldn't want to play him you
know i wouldn't want to say the words i
i think
for me as a performer it's it's my job
to open my heart up and my mind up a
little bit and empathize and
i think we could all sort of benefit
from doing this in life a little bit too
even if someone's objectively shitty
just sitting back and realizing they
come from somewhere and they come from a
set of circumstances that are probably
different to yours and whilst it doesn't
make it right
i think it's beneficial to
to even just consider it for a second
you know
and as an actor it's imperative i think
personally
just so nervous man
it's like survive survive survive
survive survive
freakishly hot all right
typing in
i already know this one's gonna yeah
whoa
yeah whoa
that's no that one's no joke well you
know if but if there's someone to blame
this is actually this is from australia
i think it's from your hometown actually
and blame me like i invented the
thirteen angry scorpions yeah like i was
before i was an actor i was just sitting
home perfecting my chili rice in the hot
sauce
in the hot chocolate my uncle like it's
good
i don't know why we're southern all of a
sudden
are you good buddy
can you talk through the moral dilemma
that you have as an actor in the
streaming era who once asked yourself in
a vanity fair profile am i the face of
this robotic terrifying new age
i was a little dramatic
which i can say now that i'm in deep
pain um
um
no i think
it's fright
sorry
don't apologize this is the show
i think when there's that much content
in the world and
we can just sit on our couches and order
food and order groceries and order
clothes and essentially not move and
just watch an endless stream
i don't think it's good for cinema i
don't think it's good for storytelling
but i don't think it's good for people
either it seems like a very sad way to
live that's a great fear to me and
because i started
in a in somewhere that
could maybe cater to that it was like
very frightening to me as a young
man and then i was also like you know
you're very convicted when you're like
18 19 you're like hell no man not me man
absolutely not me man especially a young
ambitious actor watching brando and
watching james d yeah and then you know
i thought that my gods would be looking
down at me just like spitting on me
weeping at like you know like how dare
he ought to round name
[Music]
okay
cheers
and like the last one
immediate
straight to the back of the throat
just like that
this i think will be a transformative
experience for you
this wing right here
this sauce straight to the back of the
throat yeah they didn't even they didn't
even have to
buy you dinner first
[Laughter]
the loft just cracked the pepper in my
[Music]
so i've heard you talk about forgetting
your lines at the euphoria audition and
then blowing a self tape because you're
copying zac efron's performance and
charlie saint cloud for a show that
required an american accent you do dig
you do dig
they say one thing about you
you're a digger i'm a spice man who digs
i'm a spice man who digs
i'm gonna have to go here
when you think about auditioning rock
bottom moments what immediately comes to
mind for you
um
rock bottom moment
probably
went through this one one time
i feel like i just got way cooler when i
speak yeah i went to this one place
you know because i don't try to speak
less
um
and
it was for some show and i was like
usually learn my lines but then sort of
try to play a little bit and in the
middle of the scene
this casting director was like
oh can you like she like stopped me i
was like can you just do it exactly as
the words are and i was like oh i don't
know that i'll be like reading off the
paper and she's like do that do that
read off the paper
and i started
and i was just felt so dejected that i
just left
i was like in the middle of the thing i
was like i'm not who you're looking for
because um i
had a lot of pride i guess maybe
that story makes no sense because my
mouth is so up
no you know what they tried to confine
you to the page
no they wouldn't let you color outside
the lines yeah wouldn't let peacock
creative spirit fly you gotta let me fly
gotta let you go
you gotta let jacob fly
and speaking of spreading your wings
yeah
are you ready
to move on
to the next sauce oh yeah
this is the pucker butt
extra me and green
[Music]
okay
come on man
right
so growing up in australia i understand
that you're a pretty good rugby player
before a back injury sidelined your
plane days and push you towards a career
in acting what's the key to a good
dropkick that seems like a difficult
athletic skill to perfect yep
lemonade dear um
gonna tell you a secret yeah okay
oh it's kind of like there's this
cathodic release through
through your uh muscles
oh as you enter shavasana
um i can't drop kick
i wasn't the kicker
what's the best stadium food to eat
during the match at lane park
it would probably be some form of a
sausage on bread that's my go-to i have
a very simple palette i don't like to be
you know although i said before i love
burgers with everything on them um i
have a fairly simple palette oh i'm
quite relaxed
that's what you gotta do
the cathartic release
okay
one to go
so i should eat this whole one
absolutely
here we go
[Music]
okay
all right what
we're doing it see at the bottom see at
the bottom
[Music]
a terrible idea
but it was yours uh-huh so i'll stand
back it's yours yeah i'll stand by it
[Music]
you said i'm champion
closing out another episode of hot ones
and what we're gonna do here is prey on
your hot sauce fueled vulnerability for
a quick association game okay okay i'll
point to a sauce and you just tell me
the first australian slang word or
phrase that comes to mind okay
13 angry scorpions
bloody hell
[Music]
go again
about to bomb beyond insanity oh this is
an impossible game
crikey
and last but not least the last app
apollo the one that we just ate through
it's like you bloody ripper
[Laughter]
jacob o'lordy taking on the hot ones
gauntlet had not explored the hot sauce
subculture of australia got a crash
course today and aced that test and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life um
i'm super stoked really really glad to
be here um
um yep
yep
got this guy just got this check it out
[Music]
look at you oh yeah that's an actor
that's an actor right there
you know what i mean he's immersing
himself in the experience i shouldn't
know if i tell you
that's commitment to craft
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience and one convenient package
i'm proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]